[Music]
Thanks for coming, by the way, and uh
for sticking around for a little while.
Um, if you aren't prepared, I hate to
break it to you, but this time next
year, half of us won't even be here
anymore. That's basically if you listen
to whatever the hype is about AI and AI
coding. You know, there's lots of
fanfare, no disrespect, very intelligent
people um that made these quotes. Um but
I think they're probably wrong. Not
because I don't think AI coding is going
somewhere important, but probably
because they haven't actually touched a
production system in a very very long
time. And so maybe generating code at
30% isn't really what they think it is
because
really AI code is still code. One thing
they don't really recognize in this
space is that they're working in very
very very large code bases that have
basically every decision that's ever
needed to be made about that code, about
that architecture, about that
infrastructure has already been made for
them. So if I'm generating 30% of my
code against, you know, let's say
they're doing thousands of lines a day
against millions of lines of new code of
of existing code, there's not a lot of
wiggle room for what that code can do or
should do, right? Like it's just another
button. If you've ever, no offense,
anyone from meta here before I start
ripping on meta. No, no meta. Great.
I'll rip on meta for a minute. If you've
ever talked to a meta engineer, they
will talk about how they built a button
in the ads platform for six months. like
that's that's what they worked on for
six months. That was their job. So like
there's very little definition about
like what this can needs to do that has
wiggle room that AI really struck can
influence. Next AI is still writing
code. This is code we have written for
50 years. Same programming languages.
Nothing is different there. That code
still needs to run in production
somewhere. And if you're not familiar
with if you haven't run a large
production system, even if you write a
great line of code, in complex systems,
things fail. Like complex systems have
emergent behavior that don't show up in
just single lines of code. And so we
still have to run this stuff. And so
who's going to fix it? Who's going to
examine it? Who's going to understand
those nuances when uh when if you don't
have software engineers? So I think
we're still going to have software
engineers. And then also history repeats
itself. This is not the first time I
have been told that my career is over.
Um, I'm getting in on the on the years
at this point in time, but anyone uh
around like the DevOps transformation
from 15 years ago, cloud, all the all
the CIS admins that I know that were
racking boxes and booting kernels, all
got payraises and all work on much more
valuable things now. They're much
happier doing the work they're doing.
So, this isn't new. This is just a
different level of abstraction, right?
Like tractors didn't get rid of farms.
They just got rid of farm hands and
horses. Yeah. Like yes, there will be
change in an industry for certain. But
tractors didn't get rid of farming. We
still have to farm.
So vibes. Anyone here a vibe coder? It's
okay if you are. No shame. Anyone and
who here thinks call would call
themselves a soft a professional
software engineer? Great. So vibe
coding, if you're not familiar with the
term, I think everyone in this room is,
but I'll do a quick summary, is
basically letting the AI write all of
the code and think through the code and
not really examining the code at all.
Just does it do what I need it to do?
And then in that case, like I just keep
going and let it keep going. Let keep
going. Don't don't examine the code and
edit it that way. But that's not what
we're talking about. We're I'm talking
about how can we write code that's for
production. And when I say production, I
mean, you you have four nines. Do you
even know what 49s means? That's
production code. You have thousands of
users, gigabytes of data. We're talking
software that runs the internet today.
Vibes don't cut that because there's a
lot of like nuances on what goes into
code. So, first let's clear up one
misconception. Code is not the job in
the same way that blueprints are not the
job of an architect. That's an artifact
of being an architect. The artifact of
being a a software developer is code.
Sure. Yeah, I have to output some code,
but I make thousands of decisions about
what my software is supposed to do, what
kind of what I'm writing, what packages
I'm bringing in. So, let's stop
conflating generating code with the art
and the the craft of doing software
engineering. Those are different things.
And so, yes, LLMs are great at producing
code, but are they is that the same as
writing production software?
So, a very smart person that uh started
Stack Overflow, Jeff Atwood, rest in
peace, Stack Overflow, um said the best
code is no code at all. And I think
that's true because every line of code
comes with comes with a burden, right? I
have to maintain that code. I have to
debug that code. So, every line of code
I generate I have to be responsible for.
And so, we've been we spent so much time
thinking about like how much code can AI
generate? Who cares how much it can
generate? the more it generates, the
worse off I end up being, worse off the
system ends up being. We want to put as
little code as possible in there because
all codes has trade-offs, right? Like we
recognize this package has this
performance characteristic. This this
methodology has this the best example I
can give you which I'll I'll try to get
through so you can all get back to
snacks is the difference between like a
monolith uh an microservices
architecture and an adventure system.
How many decisions go into those kinds
of architectures and the choices you
have to make to do the same thing? Like
if you ever if you built a flight
booking system in all three of these,
you have thousands of individual
decisions that have to get made. LLMs
don't make decisions. They generate
text. They generate patterns. And at
some scale, at some point, there's no
pattern for my software. Anyone here run
a piece of production software that's
kind of a bit of a snowflake? Has a
bunch of like idiosyncrasies in it that
like well only Bob knows how that works
and only Jane can fix that. She wrote it
six years ago and hasn't been on the
project and that is software. So at some
scale pattern matching doesn't work
anymore because all of the nuances that
go into all that software can't be
pattern matched against. So when when
the software is going down, this is my
like trauma of like carrying a pager.
When when software goes down at two in
the morning, vibes aren't going to fix
the bug. Like someone has to diagnose
that problem. So what is the work of
software engineering? For me, that's
changing software safely. That's been my
job for 20 years is how can I make
changes to software, whether that's
adding new functionality or changing
existing code. And how do I do it safely
so that software doesn't go down? So my
users get their get the thing that
they're getting, they the widget ships,
that um you know, data is secure. So,
how do we how have we done that so far
in the industry? We've done lots of
different things to solve that problem.
One, there's just my own knowledge. I
have to like learn a ton about a
codebase before I can make changes
safely. Uh, we use version control to do
that. We know testing, you know, like
that's why we write tests to catch if
like if I change this, did this thing
break over here? Um, we use type
systems. We use deployment strategies.
Can AI start to help us? Can context
that an AI has about and can understand
more of the codebase help us? probably
you know at augment we believe that
context is like the most important part
of all AI generation in code so yeah we
think we can solve that problem that
doesn't change that I still have to care
about production so let's just assume
that we're writing code like okay the
world is the future is here I have to
use AI um the thing I find the most
interesting about this space I've been
in it a long time in this in dev tools
for a long time is professional software
engineers are the last people I see
adopting AI and I've never seen that
before like I've seen version control
systems change I was at GitHub in early
days so like massive jumps to get uh the
cloud transformation uh pick your pick
your innovation and developers are like
hell yes give me that new thing I don't
know why well I have some hypothesis but
I don't fully understand why software
developers are like I'm not touching
code I'm not touching AI it's like it
can't do what it's going to do So I want
to talk about that for just just a
couple minutes. So a few years ago, AI
coding was mostly just a pile of bricks.
Like it kind of worked but really didn't
do much. Um about a year ago, you know,
years and change when Sonic uh 35 came
out, that's really when we saw a massive
explosion um in in AI coding because the
quality substantially jumped. Um, and
then four weeks ago, if you weren't
watching the news, literally every AI
coding tool said like agents are the
future. Uh, we did. Um, very proud of
that. But like now agents are
everywhere, right? And so this
transformation has happened uh very very
quickly. Uh, and so I want to talk about
how we can talk do software engineering
with this new future that we're seeing.
Um, so how do you build software that's
easy for AI to write? Uh, a couple tips
for you. Um, have some documented
standards and practices, right? Like
what do you use? Every codebase I know
is in some sort of flux, right? So like
are we using this package or this
package? Okay, well document that. Let
the AI know that this is the next
direction of your codebase. Um, have
reproducible environments, right? Like
can you easily spin up a developer
environment? Is your developer
environment very bespoke and unique? Um,
you want to have it reproducible. We
want to have easy testing, right? like
can you run your tests locally? Can is
that fast? Uh you know that's pretty
pretty standard stuff. Um establish
clear boundaries of what you're going to
do. You're never going to give AI the
idea of like uh extract this module
using the strangler pattern. What does
that even mean to an AI like that's a
whole you have to give clear boundaries
of what you're trying to build and how
to get the AI to do it. And lastly like
have clearly defined tasks and work. Um
because AI is going to be as you know I
wouldn't give any engineer on my team
whether they're senior staff junior just
a vague task of like could you make this
button do something different like I see
too many engineers prompting in that way
and what's interesting about this to me
is like this just sounds like software
engineering right like if we don't if
ideally your software engineering stack
looks has these qualities and if it
doesn't you're like our productivity
sucks because we have you know bespoke
testing infrastructure ffstruure. We
have bespoke developer environments. You
have to give AI the same tools that
engineers need because it's doing
exactly the same job. It's writing code.
I've never one-shot at a piece of code
in my life personally. Like I've always
made mistakes in the code I write. I run
a test, it fails. I've got a llinter, it
fixes it, whatever thing is. But we've
had this expectation that AI can like
write perfect code. And I don't know
why. And so when you're thinking about
adopting AI as a software engineer, you
have to make sure that your your systems
work like you would expect any other
engineer to work because that's how it's
writing code.
The next thing is code review is by far
the most important skill. Um I think
we've probably forgotten that skill as
an industry. Um we probably should have
been interviewing for code review and
not like here's this esoteric leak code
problem that you could solve, but like
can you read somebody else's code and
comment on why it's good or bad? Um, I
think this is going to become far more
important as agents are writing more and
more code and our code review tools
today frankly suck. Like I'm getting a
list of changed files. It's
lexographically sorted. So like great
file A changed. Let me read what changed
in file A. What changed in file B?
That's not a way to think about how
software changes is in the order of the
files. And so I think we're going to see
a pretty big explosion on the way code
review can happen. Um, and that's the
skill we need to be interviewing for.
you need to be um like kind of brushing
up on.
All right, I'm running quick on time.
So, I do want to give you a couple
highlights of like if you are one of
those software engineers is like I
don't, you know, I'm not I don't trust
AI. I need some tips. I want to give
leave you a few of these. Um feel free
to take a screenshot. One, the most
important thing I can imagine is AI
talks like a human but is actually a
machine. I had this interaction with AI
the other day where it was like uh you
know I was yelling at it because that's
what you do at AI when it doesn't do
what you want it to do. And it's like oh
I'm sorry I just scanned that file. I
didn't read it. I'm like the does
that even mean? What? How does a piece
of software scan a file? It just like
skimmed it. Like that's not a thing in
software. It's because LLMs are trained
on all the data in the world, right?
There are thousands of emails that it
has read that says like oh sorry I
didn't read your document thoroughly. I
actually just skimmed it. It's like, oh,
that's what I should say when someone's
yelling at me about not reading a file,
right? And so, we have we have to
distrust some of the things that LLMs
are saying they're doing because it's
not actually doing that. Don't forget,
it's just generating text. It's not
always doing exactly what you're what
it's outputting in that text. So, keep
that in mind when you're write when
you're reading through LLM output. Um,
let's see what other tip quick tips can
I give you. Sometimes code is just
different. It's okay if the LLM outputs
code differently than you would. I can't
expect it to produce the code that I
would exactly in the same way that like
the person that's sitting next to me
also writes code a little differently
than I do. And so just accept that
that's okay. And if you want to force it
to write code like you, you can spend
that energy, but know the difference of
is the code better or is it just
different? And so let go of some of that
like this is how you know we this is why
we have llinters. This is why we have
rule systems. This is why we have style
guides. So we can stop arguing about
like is that how you define a function
or is this how you define a function.
Let some of that go if you can. Um write
a rules file. You know give it tell it
what you want it to do. Have a file. I
always start all of my projects with
like here's the stack I'm using. Here's
the like guidelines I want you to use.
And that's always ends up being part of
the context I send with the LLM. Um, and
then lastly, I like to define create
refine loop. Expect create a a document
of some kind. Have the LM help you
generate it. Like I'm doing this thing.
Write a markdown file that would like
lay out the plan. Here's my plan. Save
that as a markdown file. Then use that
again in your context. Have it create
the thing. Have the agent run against
that file. You know, you can make your
edits to it and then refine it. then
you're going in with, you know, code
completions or whatever to like just
tweak the things that you want to tweak
and just do that loop over and over and
over again. Make a plan, have it create
it, and then just make your make your
tweaks and you'll get a lot more
comfortable one how to prompt the LLM to
get the code you want to do as well as
um that's just a very efficient way of
coding. And if you've let go if you let
go of that code has to be how I would
write it, not just good functional code,
then you can get a lot more productive
in that way. Um, thanks again. Uh, I
blasted through that. I'm happy to talk.
Augment is in the expo hall. I'll be
around there to chat or over here. Um, I
hope to see you here next year. Hope
we're all here next year. I think the
jobs aren't going anywhere. Um, but
happy coding. Really appreciate it.
[Music]